قال الصحفي اماال زقوت ان قصفا اسرائيليا
استهدف مدرسه عمواس غرب جباليا النزله
وادى الى استشهاد خمسه فلسطينيين ممن
نزحوا الى تلك المدرسه مشيرا الى ان
المسيرات الاسرائيليه ما زالت تحلق بشكل
مكثف في سماء شمال
غزه الاوضاع في شمال قطاع
غزه المدفعيه الاسرائيليه والطائرات
المسيره الاسرائيليه استهدفت بشكل المباشر
ومركز منطقه المصريين في بيت حنون واطلقت
هذه القدف تجاه تجمعات للمواطنين
الفلسطينين في تلك المنطقه وكذلك تعرضت
مدرسه عمواس وهي تقع الى الغرب من جباليا
النزله الى قصف اسرائيلي استشهد على اثره
خمسه مواطنين ممن نزحوا الى تلك المدرسه
وكذلك استشهد مواطن مواطن سادس في ذات
المدرسه ب رصاص قناص
اسرائيلي الاليات العسكريه تتواجد الى
الغرب من جباليه النزله وكذلك الى الشرق
من جباليا البلد منطقه جباليا البلد تعرضت
ل في الايام الاخيره الى عمليه عسكريه
مركزه
واستهداف لتلك المدينه التي تعرضت ل تدمير
كامل كبير
و كبير في تلك المنطقه وايضا هنالك المسي
الاسرائيليه هي ما زالت تحلق بشكل كثيف في
اجواء متفرقه من شمال قطع غزه الاوضاع
المعيشيه هي اوضاع ماساويه في منطقه شمال
قطع غزه نتيجه عدم وصول المساعدات منذ
فتره طويله الموارد الاساسيه باتت تخلو من
البيوت ومن مدارس اللواء في الشمال كذلك
الشمال يعاني من الانقطاع التام للتيار
الكهربائي وكذلك شبك الاتصالات والانترنت
التي انقطعت عن العالم بسبب هذه هذا
التخريب الذي جرى لشبكات الانترنت
والاتصالات والتيار الكهربائي هذا هو
الوضع العام الان في شمال قطع
غزه